trop défi communiste communisants
d'hommes semblables impôts
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
scopeo l'observatoire politique je suis
lucas da silva cofondateur de scopeo et
je vous souhaite aujourd'hui la
bienvenue sur ce huitième épisode de
notre série
l'entrevue politique aujourd'hui nous
sommes très honorés de recevoir monsieur
gilles raveaud pour discuter d'économie
mais avant tout je laisse la parole à
lucas période pour pour qu'ils puissent
poser le décor de ce nouveau podcast
merci lucas bonjour aux à celles et à
ceux qui nous écoutent et surtout
bonjour à vous messieurs gilles ragon
bonjour pardon excusez moi tu t'es déjà
parce que nous avons envoyé plein de
questions génial super concentré vous ne
faites donc le plaisir aujourd'hui nous
accordé cette entrevue pour discuter
ensemble de votre sujet de prédilection
qui est l'économie en effet le thème de
cet entretien saturé en partie sur votre
courage
économie on n'a pas tout essayé et sur
vos analyses sur le modèle libéral qui
convient de dépasser selon mais avant de
démarrer l'entrevue messieurs gilles
raveaud je vous laisse vous présenter
brièvement pour ceux qui nous écoutent
moi je suis professeur d'économie
j'enseigne dans une université du nord
de la région parisienne qui s'appelle
université paris 8 et qui n'est pas
situé à paris qui est située en seine
saint denis hassen hamdy précisément
enfin nous nous génie de
l'administration publique publics ont
réussi à mettre ma faculté en banlieue
de saint denis ce qui est assez
remarquable pour une facture au milieu
de rien on n'a même pas qu'il a fait aux
côtes à côtes et c'est vraiment sympa
donc voilà j'ai des étudiants géniaux
heureusement qu'ils viennent d'un peu
partout qui sont ultra intéressant
j'adore mon métier je suis très triste à
cause de la situation nous connaissons
tout ce je n'ai pas pu les voir en vrai
depuis le mois d'octobre dernier et donc
je me rattrape en vendée petite vidéo
alors oui c'est une situation qu'on
connaît très bien parce que nous sommes
nous mêmes étudiants qu'on traverse
depuis un nombre qui est assez
compliquée pour l'enseignement supérieur
en particulier mais pour entrer dans le
vif du sujet pour pour attaquer ce
modèle libéral que vous vous se poser un
autre modèle dans tout au long de votre
ouvrage
pouvez vous nous expliquer pour
commencer selon vous en quoi la france
est un pays libéral économiquement tout
en gardant bien à l'esprit que notre
pays est souvent décrit comme le
champion du monde des impôts
parmi les pays développés avec un taux
de prélèvements obligatoires se situant
au tout
2 46% par rapport à notre pib alors je
pense sérieusement pour vraiment
répondre à cette question il faut deux
heures donc on va évidemment faire plus
court alors la première chose c'est le
terme de libéra que je pense est le
principal problème de notre époque c'est
à dire que le libéralisme économique
s'est imposé comme terme sur la planète
en particulier depuis les années 80 et
là la révolution à la fois politique de
ronald reagan de maggie thatcher et sur
le plan théorique de milton friedman
tout ça c'est nouveau n'est venu des
états unis
ces gens là se sont dits libéraux au
sens où ils ont contesté en fait
l'intervention de l'état
donc l'idée c'était comme donc c'est
tout ça de libérer les entreprises
vis-à-vis de l'emprise de l'état de
libérer les individus vis-à-vis de
l'emprise de l'état
mais comme le dit j'ai fait un petit peu
la promotion de les petits camarades
comme le dit par exemple très bien
bernard maris ce ce très joli livre
souriez vous êtes français azul et
découvrir qui était bernard maristes
donc mon ancien collègue de paris 8 qui
a été assassiné à charlie hebdo le 7
janvier 2015
c'est une collection de chroniques qu'il
a faite à la radio donc c'est très court
très facile à lire dans ce livre d'un
amary sy nous dit qu est ce qui nous
rend libres
qu'est ce qui nous rend libres si les
services publics pourquoi est-ce qu'on
est libre nous français ou plus
exactement nous habitants de france
français et étrangers habitant en france
pourquoi ce qu'on est libre parce qu'on
a grosso modo même si c'est de moins en
moins drain l'éducation gratuite parce
qu'on a la santé gratuite parce qu'on a
la police gratuite dans à tout un tas de
pays boos votre sécurité vous devez
l'acheter avec des milices privées si
vous avez de l'argent ou encore plus si
vous êtes pour d'ailleurs d'accord donc
je pense que le terme de libéral était
extrêmement problématique c'est mon
premier mois deuxième point
effectivement en quoi on est dans un
pays libéral tout simplement parce que
les entreprises appartiennent être des
individus et non pas des collectifs
ce premier critère c'est à dire que
nous avons très peu d'entreprises
nationalisé en france aujourd'hui ont
très peu d'entreprises publiques presque
plus et rien ne vous empêche comme le
souhaitait emmanuel macron début de son
mandat de créer votre entreprise votre
fameux de start-up jeunes pousses en bon
français et de devenir milliardaire
d'autre part c'est vrai qu'on paie
beaucoup d'impôts en france
mais quand vous regardez les articles
dans la presse vous savez peut-être que
on est un des pays au monde où ramené à
la population
il ya le plus de milliardaires donc
l'idée selon laquelle ce serait
impossible de devenir riche en france
elle est complètement fausse
si on dit ça c'était le deuxième point
si on va sur le plan un peu plus
théorique
qu'est ce que c'est que le capitalisme
donc c'est dire dans les premier critère
c'est la propriété privée des moyens de
production
mais là où le capitalisme est génial et
c'est une des plus grandes découvertes
de karl marx au milieu du dix neuvième
siècle le philosophe allemand karl marx
il nous dit ce qui est génial avec le
capitalisme
le fric qu'on a moins confiance bon
français du capitalisme c'est que vous
avez justement toutes les apparences de
la liberté le capitaliste un système
très récent dans l'histoire de
l'humanité il s'est diffusée à l'échelle
de la planète depuis en gros deux
siècles vraiment avant dans la plupart
des sociétés vous n'étiez pas libre vous
n'étiez pas libre du temps vous n'étiez
pas libre de vous déplacer vous n'étiez
pas libres de choisir votre métier
encore moins si vous êtes une femme très
souvent vous deviez reprendre le métier
de votre père etc
vous avez des corporations qui régissait
très très durement le fonctionnement
l'activité économique se sont d'ailleurs
contre ces corporations qu'adam smith le
soi-disant père du libéralisme écrivait
en 1776 et semi justement revendiquer la
liberté la vraie liberté pour les gens
d'exercer le métier qu'ils voulaient
donc il était en guerre contre les
corporations qui régissait absolument
tout à l'époque qui disaient combien de
temps quelle personne devait effectuer
qu'elle travaille pour quel salaire etc
etc
à l'époque l'état nick se passe sous sa
forme moderne évidemment
vous avez ces corporations et donc smith
c'est un défenseur de la liberté ex miss
avec 6 7767 carmarks il arrive beaucoup
plus tard à partir des années 1850 et
marx il nous dit ce qui est génial à
dans le capitalisme c'est que vous avez
notamment le fameux marché du travail
c'est à dire que personne personne ne
vous met un pistolet soudas temps pour
aller travailler dans un autre emploi
entrepôts amazon personnes alors qu'il
ya plein de système économique vous êtes
obligés de faire les choses par exemple
l' esclavage esclavage qui existent
toujours sur la planète high très grande
initiative la chaîne américaine cnn et
quelques années pour lutter contre l'
esclavage moderne qui concerne des
dizaines de millions de personnes dans
le monde il y a bien sûr des esclaves
dans le monde entier il y à des esclaves
dans le 16e arrondissement de paris à
des femmes étrangères auxquels les
familles fortunées retire leurs
passeports qui sont ensuite exploitées
qui ne parle pas français ne peuvent pas
repartir dans leur pays qu'ils sont
abusés de plein de manières on peut
facilement imaginer et qui soit au
service des grandes familles de leurs
enfants etc
ce sont des esclaves il ya des esclaves
mais ce que nous dit marx c'est que donc
justement de ce qui définit le
capitalisme premier critère on l'a dit
la propriété privée des entreprises
deuxième critère la liberté sur le
marché du travail qui fait que en
apparence un personne n'oblige personne
à se faire exploiter même si évidemment
plein de gens le font parce qu'ils ont
faim et le troisième critère que nous
dit marc ce qui nous amène à la
catastrophe écologique actuelle c'est
l'accumulation il faut bien voir que
marx n'est pas du tout du tout un
théoricien du socialisme il faut des
moyens en mars à savoir
et quand vous lisez marque ce qu'est ce
qui fait il décrit ce qui est en train
de se passer
il est en angleterre ils voient les
immenses manufacture qui se met en place
et marx c'est le sait le fameux numéro
un du capitalisme il dit mais c'est
génial et m
mais c'est une révolution il remplace le
terme de révolution et nous dit le
capitalisme c'est une accumulation de
marchandises
combien n'a jamais eu dans l'histoire de
l'humanité évidemment il a raison il
comprend tout à ce qui se passe et c'est
pour ça notamment le manifeste du parti
communiste texte très très court et très
faciles à lire qu'il a co écrit avec
engels a longtemps à terre des textes
les plus lus sur la planète avec la
bible est ce que ce sont des gars comme
smith comme keynes qui observe la
réalité ce sont des gens qui sont autant
journalistes que théoricien qui
connaissent parfaitement le monde dans
lequel ils vivent et qui voit le nouveau
monde arriver martine aubry ce qui
définit le capitalisme ce qui fait la
rupture fondamentale dans l'histoire de
l'humanité c'est que le capitalisme
c'est l'accumulation c'est le toujours
plus et donc de ce point de vue là en
france on est bien effectivement dans un
pays capitaliste dans un pays
d'immigrants dernier point sur les
impôts sans être trop long il faut
savoir que en france la principale
dépense publique n'est pas une dépense
publique
la principale dépense publique en france
et la sécurité sociale qu'est ce que
c'est la sécurité sociale ce sont des
sommes que vous vous verser à vous même
c'est à dire que quand vous êtes jeunes
en bonne santé et que vous travaillez
vous payer beaucoup de cotisations
sociales mais ces cotisations sociales
voulais retrouver quand vous êtes en
congé maladie vous voulez retrouver
quand vous avez des enfants vous les
retrouverez beaucoup et surtout quand
vous serez à la retraite et ses
cotisations sociales vous les avez déjà
touché quand vous étiez enfant c'est vos
parents qui l'ont touché paumé qui ont
permis de lever les impôts vous avez
payez vous avez touché par l'éducation
gratuite à laquelle vous avez bénéficié
la police gratuite
la santé très largement gratuit les
routes gratuite et c'est donc en fait
c'est de l'argent que vous versez à vous
même et d'autre part je pas tant
développés mais il faut savoir tout
expliquer dans plusieurs textes des gens
comme jean gadrey aussi on fait le ratio
de dépenses publiques sur pv n'a
strictement aucun sens il explique
rapidement
imaginons l'aller sinon les deux lucas
vous êtes en couple et vous touchez je
ne sais pas 1000 euros par mois chacun
d'accord donc le revenu du foyer ses
2000 euros et on va dire je sais pas il
ya un des deux lucas qui fait la
vaisselle et un autre j'en sais rien qui
fait le des travaux de bricolage dans la
maison et y en a un
chacun va payer 100 euros à l'autre
l'un des tâches ménagères l'autre pour
le bricolage
on va appeler ça supposons pour faire le
parallèle avec les taxes assez des
dépenses publiques d'accord ces dépenses
publiques du fruit ça fait 200 lots on a
dit que vous touchez 1000 euros chacun
ça fait 2000 au donc le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires
c'est 10% si je vous dis que toute prime
obligatoire de votre foyer c'est 10%
ça donne forcément la pression tout le
monde qui a 10 % que vous perdez que
vous donnez à l'état mais non voyons
bien voulu donner à vous même et bien
nos impôts nos cotisations sociales en
france pour la très très grand pas c'est
de l'argent que nous nous donnons à nous
mêmes soit plus tard d'antan avec la
retraite soit comme nous sommes malades
soit avec les infrastructures publiques
donc l'immense majorité des impôts et
des cotisations sociales très
sérieusement ce sont de l'argent que
nous donnons est donc le ratio dépense
publique sur pib qui fait penser qu'il
ya une part du pib qui serait prélevée
par l'état et qui seraient retirés des
gens c'est empiriquement faux et ce
ratio je suis désolé n'a strictement
aucun sens et tous les gens qui
l'utilisent comme je suis
malheureusement obligés de le faire
aussi de temps en temps parce que tout
le monde utilise ce ratio n'a
strictement aucun sens
alors messieurs à vos vous avez déjà un
peu être évoqué les inégalités en
parlant des milliardaires français
rappelons quelques chiffres que vous
citez dans votre livre 47 % de la
richesse nationale totale est captée par
les 10% de la population les plus riches
en france
en parallèle on observe une fracture
générationnelle prononcé pour les moins
de 30 ans le patrimoine moyen de 37000
euros tandis que pour les sexagénaires
il est 2 340 mille euros peut-on par
conséquent dire qu'il ya des inégalités
opposant des générations en france
faut-il alors s'attaquer à notre système
de retraites comme le gouvernement a
cherché à le faire avant la crise à
l'italie
donc effectivement ça c'est des chiffres
très importants à connaître déjà tout
simplement devrait être enseigné à tout
le monde
le simple fait que ces chiffres qui sont
publiques qui sont faciles à connaître
qui ont été popularisée notamment par
les travaux de thomas piketty qui a
énormément fait progresser la
connaissance dans ce domaine au cours
des dernières décennies
ces chiffres devraient être enseignées à
tous les collégiens les lycéens le fait
qu'il ne soit pas cette année d'un
problème et pour moi c'est un des plus
graves
même notre démocratie que c'est la
première et la deuxième chose c'est que
dans la presse dans les débats
politiques on parle beaucoup plus des
revenus que des patrimoines alors qu'est
ce que c'est que le revenu qu'est ce que
c'est que les patrimoines suffit de
regarder les mots le revenu c'est ce qui
revient le revenu c'est ce qui revient
tous les mois et le patrimoine
étymologiquement c'est ce qui vient du
père c'est ce qui est transmis notamment
par l'héritage
effectivement quand on regarde les
inégalités de revenus entre quelqu'un
qui mettons touchent l'allocation du
revenu de solidarité active tous les
mois est quelqu'un qui est cadre
supérieur y aura peut-être un rapport
béton de rein à 10,2 à un béton que la
personne au rsa vient toucher 500 euros
par mois
le cadre supérieur a touché dix mille
euros par mois ça fait un rapport 2 av
mais on sait bien tous quand on se
promène dans notre pays il ya des gens
qui ont des très grandes maisons il ya
des gens qui ont des jardins
il ya des gens qui ont des belles
voitures qui ont plusieurs maisons qui
prennent beaucoup de vacances et d'un
autre côté il y en a d'autres qui vivent
dans des logements dégradés ou ils ont
froid l'hiver qui sont bruyants qui sont
mal situé qu'ils sont petits qui ont des
problèmes d'inondations etc ou leurs
enfants s'entassent éventuellement donc
on sait que les conditions de vie en
france n'ont rien à voir entre les
différentes parties de la population et
on sait aussi
ah si on arrête de se mentir il sont
justes on observe la réalité on sait
très bien d'où viennent ces inégalités
c'est que très majoritairement les gens
qui sont riches sont riches parce qu'ils
sont riches ils sont riches parce qu'ils
ont bien choisi leur parent et que leurs
parents étaient déjà riche car
évidemment en france personne n'est
riche à vous le savez cette différence
extase unis tout le monde est dans la
classe moyenne est donc évidemment
personne ne se pense comme riche
moi-même évidemment je ne pense pas du
tout comme riche alors je sais que je le
suis très clairement par rapport à la
rapport aux statistiques mais comme tout
le monde je regarde au dessus de moi je
regarde mes cousins qui ont des maisons
beaucoup plus grande que la mienne qui
partent beaucoup plus souvent que moi à
l'étranger etc
donc personne est riche mais en fait il
ya une richesse colossale dans ce pays
évidemment cette richesse est totalement
injuste puisqu'elle dépend encore une
fois totalement de la naissance alors là
aussi les légendes qui courent en france
selon laquelle les [ __ ] serait hyper
taxe est simplement c'est faux
simplement c'est faux donc christian
chavagneux qui est vraiment quelqu'un il
faut absolument lire journaliste
internet qu'il est qu'elle fait
plusieurs articles et ils m'ont pas nous
que lorsque on s'intéresse au principal
héritage c'est à celui qu'on laisse à
nos enfants qui s'appelle l'héritage en
ligne directe et bien le taux
d'imposition moyen sur cet héritage
c'est pas 30%
c'est par un passant s'est pas 10% c'est
3% il ya 3 % des sommes qui sont légués
par leurs parents à leurs enfants qui
sont captés par l'état
lorsque je comprends très bien et que
comme être humain je vis comme tout le
monde sait que taxer l'héritage c'est
extrêmement extrêmement violent vous le
fait perdre vos parents le simple fait
qu'on vous prenne le stress 15 euros
c'est insoutenable
je suis entièrement d'accord avec ce
simplement parce que j'aimerais
souligner c'est que si on était libéral
si vous êtes libéral au mauvais sens
qu'on a donné au début c'est à dire si
vous êtes pour la concurrence
généralisée
si vous êtes pour la responsabilité
individuelle complète et totale
évidemment vous êtes totalement opposé à
l'héritage puisque la définition
philosophique de notre société qui est
incarné comme jamais par emmanuel macron
sais tu as que tu là il ya des gens qui
ne sont rien comme l'a dit le président
publiquement et des gens qui ne sont
rien et il ya des gens qui sont riches
comme son ami xavier niel le fondateur
pdg de flux et chacun a ce qu'il mérite
c'est la course de tous contre tous
c'est une idéologie qu'évidemment
délirante détruit détruit la société
évidemment ce fausse puisque je vois que
mes étudiants ceux qui décrochent les
meilleurs stages c'est ce dont les
parents ou les familles les
connaissances bosse dans les meilleures
boîtes vous vivez aussi comme étudiant
donc ce fantasme de la concurrence pure
et parfaite comme si on était tous
alignés comme jeux olympiques sur la
ligne de départ avec tout le monde avait
les mêmes chances ça n'a aucun sens et
alors ils tout le monde n'a pas les
mêmes chances évidemment si vous
regardez les médailles olympiques
quel est le premier prédicteurs du
nombre de médailles olympiques d'un pays
et bien c'est sa richesse et son pib par
habitant
c'est très simple plus vous êtes riche
plus vous gagnez deux médailles aux jo
pour des raisons évidentes
donc quoi qu'on pense d'eux les [ __ ]
il faut bien comprendre ça me semble
quand même très très important que si
vous êtes sérieusement favorable à ce
qu'on appelle la méritocratie c'est à
dire à chacun selon ses mérites
vous avez vous êtes totalement
totalement opposé à l'héritage romain
juste après est-ce que vous pourrez
évoqué un petit peu la question des
retraites le cas et c'est de ce qui
s'est fait après ok d'accord alors vous
êtes dur et c'est donc sur les retraites
là il faut savoir que c'est
malheureusement un problème totalement
inventé c'est à dire que ça fait partie
de ces problèmes ou malheureusement il y
as un serment une groupe de gens qui
sont des haut fonctionnaires qui sont
des gens qui sont en france tratégie par
exemple organismes publics le cas
succéder au commissariat non qu'elle
soit bercy qui sont dans les ministères
sur les gens qui ont été formés plutôt
des formes et à polytechnique hec à
l'ena sciences po dont les facultés
d'économie et ces gens là sont persuadés
qu'il existe un problème des retraites
ils sont persuadés depuis des décennies
qu'il existe un promeneur
en fait quand on regarde la réalité ce
problème la première chose c'est très
largement il n'existe pas
vous allez retrouver facilement l'année
dernière une note signée je crois à
l'époque de gérald darmanin et marlène
schiappa publié il ya un an ou deux
évidemment avant la crise du cône qui
expliquait que le régime général des
retraites était équilibré pourquoi ce
que ce régime équilibré tout simplement
parce qu'on a beaucoup augmenté la durée
de cotisation et que donc il ya de moins
en moins de gens qui arrivent à cotiser
durant toute la durée nécessaire et donc
en fait que leur retraite elles baissent
c'est à dire que moi mes parents qui ont
75 ans font partie de la génération qui
a des retraités de lui mais ça s'est
fini c'est fini pour toujours d'accord
donc en fait je prenne des retraites
il n'existe pas très largement la
deuxième chose comme je l'expliqué dans
une autre vidéo qui a pas mal circulé
c'est qu'il ya des fonds de réserve très
important qui nous garantisse un avenir
sans aucune inquiétude pour le régime
des retraites même avec le cobaye pour
des années et des années
la troisième chose c'est que comment ça
fonctionne le système mis en place ce
système j'ai bien on a le meilleur
système au monde pas parce qu'on est
français on n'est pas les seuls à avoir
c'est que de l'argent est prélevé tous
les mois sur les gens qui travaillent et
verser tous les mois aux gens qui sont à
la retraite il faut quand même bien que
les gens sachent que c'est d'un point de
vue économique le système le plus
efficace au monde parce que les coûts
intermédiaires c'est quasiment zéro tout
ça ça se passe par l'informatique
il ya très très peu de gens à la caisse
d'assurance vieillesse qui gère tout ça
par rapport à la masse qui est gérée il
faut bien savoir que ce système public
est tellement décriée par tous nos
dirigeants depuis des décennies est
littéralement dix fois plus efficace dix
fois plus efficace joseph stiglitz
notamment l'avait démontré que toutes
les banques les assurances privées
les mutuelles auquel vous cotisez tous
bons je répète la caisse d'assurance
vieillesse
vous avez un employé là où est la
société générale alan à la génération de
l'éducation nationale dans toutes les
banques à la banque soit disant
populaire chez paribas etc vous avez
littéralement dix employés ou une
personne 10 fois mieux payés que les
employés de la caisse d'assurance
vieillesse quand donc l'efficacité de
façon monstrueuse et là elle est du côté
du public
pourquoi parce que c'est un système
technique simple sans aucun
intermédiaire parce que c'est un
monopole et c'est ce que je disais tout
à l'heure c'est de l'argent que nous
versons en double
donc il faut bien comprendre que vous
avez des dames les campagnes de
publicité vous voyez partout où les
stades de foot sur des mondes mutuel
c'est vous qui les bébés c'est pas la
mutuelle il n'y a pas de stade de foot
qui s'appelle la sécurité sociale
pourquoi est ce que la sécurité sociale
a pas d'argent à perm à payer des
millionnaires en short d'accord alors
que les millionnaires en short qui sont
payés par vos banques mutuelles ou les
courses de bateaux c'est vous qui payez
c'est vous qui paie s'est jamais la
banque la banque ne payerai c'est
toujours les clients qui paient enfin si
on veut effectivement augmenter les
ressources de retraite ce que je
souhaite
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire très simple
augmenter les salaires les retraites
sont financés en proportion des salles
plus les salaires augmentent plus les
ressources pour le fonds de retraite ou
si vous êtes vraiment inquiet comme pour
l'avenir des retraites comme le sont
comme vous l'êtes peut-être comme le
sont en apparence nos dirigeants depuis
des décennies les amis augmenter les
salaires
deuxième source de financement très
importante l'emploi des femmes
il ya beaucoup de femmes qui sont
empêchés de travailler il ya beaucoup de
femmes qui travaillent à temps partiel
et beaucoup de femmes qui sont très mal
payés la plupart des travailleurs mal
payés sont des femmes
si vous permettez à ces femmes de
travailler si vous permettez à ces
femmes de passer de temps partiel à
temps complet si vous augmentez les
salaires de ces femmes
vous voyez que si vous jouez sur tous
ces leviers vous augmenter de façon
considérable régime des retraites
puisque vous augmenter les ressources du
récit et comment est ce qu'on peut faire
ça et bien suffit de suivre notamment ce
qu'ont fait les pays nordiques c'est
qu'il faut augmenter très fortement les
structures de garde d'enfants public
c'est à dire en bon français les crèches
le meilleur mise à part
d'investissements écologiques le
meilleur investissement que notre pays
aurait dû faire depuis des années qu'il
a fait d'ailleurs mais qui n'a pas fait
suffisamment mais qu'il a fait beaucoup
plus que la plupart des autres pays
c'est sûr si la crèche il ya des études
économiques très sérieuses sur des
décennies des décennies qui montre que
les enfants qui sont accueillis en
crèche parfaite vaut mieux que les
autres vont mieux que ceux qui sont
élevés par leurs parents donc je sais
que c'est extrêmement violent entendre
parler sociologique et économique
quand vous êtes accueillis dans les
structures de garde collectifs surtout
celle de la qualité dont nous avons en
france
vous apprenez à dialoguer des adultes
plusieurs vous apprenez à dialoguer avec
des enfants plusieurs vous apprenez à
interagir en société donc vous
développez vos capacités cognitives vous
apprenez à coopérer avec les autres et
donc encore une fois les études qui
existe parce qu'il ya plein d'études
génial noirmont dans tous les domaines
sur des décennies montrent que les
enfants qui sont allés à la crèche gagne
plus sombres a souvent au chômage ont
moins faire à la justice
au moins de problèmes de santé etc et
c'est évidemment d'autant plus vrai pour
les enfants venant de milieux
défavorisés
nous voyons ce qui est assez drôle et ça
ce ne sont très importantes en économie
c'est que la solution du problème
presque toujours mais pas là où est le
problème
et donc pour résumer la solution au
problème des retraites qui encore une
fois est très largement inexistant la
solution au problème des retraites c'est
de construire des crèches
merci pour cette réponse on va revenir
comme je l'annonçais sur la question de
l'héritage
donc vous êtes attaché à une sorte de
suppression ou en tout cas une meilleure
taxation de l'héritage pour une égalité
des chances dans la république française
vous dénoncer le fait que le patrimoine
en france soit très inégalitaire alors
je vais citer une nouvelle fois un
chiffre pour que nos auditeurs socke
tente bien le fossé 10 % des français
les plus pauvres disposent au maximum de
3000 euros de patrimoine net et 10 % des
français les plus riches disposent d'un
patrimoine d'au moins cinq cent trente
mille euros
alors ça ce sont des chiffres qu'on peut
une nouvelle fois trouvé dans votre
livre
alors selon vous quelles sont très
simples la question des inégalités
succession doit-elle être la priorité à
régler
alors d'abord il faut rappeler qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas de
patrimoine
il ya des gens qui laissent des têtes
des dettes leur dessert tout le monde
avec une mule pas du patrimoine propre
arme comme vous l'avez dit effectivement
les inégalités de patrimoine c'est de 1
à 100 c'est de 1 à 100 c'est absolument
martin
je pense qu'en fait on peut pas vraiment
comprendre mesurer l'ampleur des
inégalités de patrimoine de notre
société
ils travaux thomas piketty faut bien
rappeler à mme thomas piketty quand on
le lit il ya en dehors des caricatures
et d'ailleurs du titre qui donne à
certains de ses ouvrages
thomas piketty est un économiste
totalement favorable à l'économie de
marché et même à la société de marché
thomas piketty ne s'est jamais prononcée
par exemple en faveur des
nationalisations jamais il s'est jamais
prononcée même en faveur de la hausse du
smic
jamais ces propositions concernent
simplement ce qu'on appelle la
redistribution de revenus
essentiellement par la fiscal dont il
faut bien comprendre avec thomas piketty
tanner comice moderne très favorable aux
marchés c'est bien pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'il est cité élus dans le monde entier
dans le consensus idéologique actuel
et qu'est ce qu'il écrit thomas piketty
dans son premier livre le capital au
21ème siècle
en fait on voit qu'il est effrayée par
ce qu'ils découvrent
il est effrayé parce que thomas piketty
l'a fait des découvertes c'est ça qu'il
faut bien comprendre pourquoi ce qui
l'est aussi c'est l'amant c'est parce
qu'il a fait un travail absolument de
dingue alors qu'il est encore très jeune
il en gros mon âge pour produire des
données il n'est pas c'est à balader sur
les sites internet des instituts
statistiques du monde entier il a
produit 2,2 il a produit de la
connaissance et rien que pour ça on va
tous lui dire un énorme merci
et en plus il rend gratuitement
accessibles toutes ces données sur son
site data j'aimerais bien qu'un jour
notamment les jeunes les étudiants se
rend compte de la chance
hallucinante qu'ils ont d'avoir des
esprits aussi brillant qui donne accès
aussi gratuitement à la qualité et la
quantité de travail qu'ils fournissent
et j'aimerais bien je le dis de façon un
peu méchante que les étudiants se
rendent compte que c'est pas normal ça
ça gratuit tout ça et qu'il ya un moment
où on a accepté de le payer de faire de
vrais choix dans votre vie entre ce
pourquoi vous voulez payer et ce goût
ce pourquoi vous voulez pas payer je
sais que c'est brutal quand je dis ça
mais je le pense très profondément bon
bref piketty fait ça et qu'est ce qui
nous dit dans son bouquin il nous dit on
à blanc n'arrivent à une société de
petits rentiers
il est terrifiée parce que justement ça
remet en cause tout le fondement il ya
des pages très très belle très claire de
piketty là dessus de notre société soit
disant basé sur la méritocratie
qu'est ce que c'est une société de
petits rentiers société qui a existé
société de rentiers au 19e siècle en
france
c'est une société ya des gens qui ne
travaillent pas et qui gagnent plus que
se peut qu'ils travaillent et ces gens
là en particulier j'en ai connu
directement ce sont les gens qui possède
par exemple des immeubles à paris a
paris il y à des familles qui possèdent
un niveau dont qui touche vous voyez des
sommes faramineuses tous les mois sans
strictement rien
et je me rappelle pas des proportions
exactes dans les piketty dans son clip
nous dit aujourd'hui en france nous
avons de plus en plus de gens qui vont
hériter au cours de leur vie parce que
vous pouvez arrêter plusieurs enfants
qui vont hériter au cours de leur vie de
plus
plus que ce que des millions d'habitants
de france ont gagné par leur travail
moi je bouge été bouleversée quand j'ai
lu c'est pas ça remet en cause
absolument tout le fondement de notre
société et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que ça a donc piqué et il a écrit
maintenant je crois c'est pas en 2013
que son livre est sorti c'est des pages
très clair très forte et tout ça et
c'est pas ça qui a été repris dans le
débat public ce qui a été repris dans le
débat public
ses propositions à la fin qui sont pas
du tout convaincante de créer un impôt
mondial sur les revenus et c'est
d'accord donc je pourrais vous les
envoyer
si les pages que je donne à lire mes
étudiants c'est parce qu'elles sont très
très forte parce que piketty comprend ce
qui se passe il comprend vraiment ce qui
se passe c'est à dire qu'effectivement
le contrat démocratique très bancale sur
lequel nous vivons depuis des années
c'est à dire qu'en apparence
qu'est ce que c'est la démocratie la
démocratie c'est un des très rares
moments le vote plus précisément pendant
le vote
c'est un des très rares moments dans la
société ou un pauvre compte au sens
littéral du terme
autant qu'à riches quand on va voter le
dimanche 1 dans notre école primaire
j'aime bien ce petit ce petit riton
retour dans l'école où était petit on va
voter et les gens du quartier et à ce
moment là la plaie tout le monde tout le
monde vos pareils
et évidemment comme il ya plus de
pauvres que de riches un des grands
paradoxes et que les partis soutenus par
les ports devraient toujours gagner on
voit que c'est pas du tout cas toujours
est il que dans notre système dans notre
société il ya cette contradiction disons
cette tension si on veut faire un peu
plus modérée entre légalité radicale de
la démocratie ou encore une fois quand
on a voté
mon vote va compter autant que celui de
bernard arnault ou d'emmanuel macron ou
de la personne qui fait des ménages dans
les usines
tous comptes faits pareils est
évidemment dans la société tout le reste
du temps il ya des gens qui comptent
beaucoup plus que les autres parce
qu'ils ont du pouvoir sur les zones du
pouvoir économique du pouvoir politique
du pouvoir idéologique et donc piqué
tings il ya toujours eu dans notre
démocratie très récente aussi un puisque
je rappelle que les femmes de vote en
france ou en gros que depuis soixante
dix ans et qui a encore beaucoup de gens
qui sont élus exclus des des élections
comme par exemple les personnes qui sont
pas françaises qui votent pas aux
élections présidentielles même s'il
réside en france depuis longtemps bref
pic et il obtiendra ses fonctions depuis
toujours entre légalité démocratique
effectivement assez radicale du mois
juste au moment du vote
juste au moment et la vie économique qui
est de toute façon est de toute évidence
très minimes
et puis qui est il nous dit je suis
entièrement là dessus et la force de nos
sociétés jusqu'à présent c'est d'avoir
maintenu une fiction qui fait que chacun
a cru et pouvait croire d'ailleurs de
façon légitime que effectivement il
avait sa chance dans le système
économique et que donc on savait bien
qu'il y avait des inégalités mais ces
inégalités pas trop forte à 3 juste pas
trop délirante en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on a voulu croire et donc encore une
fois dans ses pages la nuque et il nous
dit ça c'est terminé s'est terminée
cette période là elle a été en fait
assez courte
en gros à la durée de 1945 jusqu'aux
années 70
à peine 30 ans et nous dit cette période
elle est terminée aujourd'hui les gens
qui ont du pouvoir dans la société ou en
plus strictement du pouvoir économique
est encore une fois peuvent et ces gens
là nous dit évidemment ils sont une
minorité mais sont de plus en plus
nombreux et qui sont de plus en plus
riches
regardez encore les chiffres les
milliardaires français sont ceux qui
sont le schiste de plus le plus
enrichissant et donc ces gens là gagnent
sans travail évidemment qu'ils
travaillent en plus laissant travailler
il gagne au cours de leur vie beaucoup
plus que ce que des millions d'habitants
de notre pays vont gagner par leur dure
vie de travail en faisant comme on l'a
vu de la crosse du covin les boulots les
plus utiles qui comme chacun le sait
maintenant ce sont aussi les plus mal
payés donc là il ya une rupture de la
promesse encore une fois la promesse
égalitaire n'a jamais été vérifiées dans
les faits mais piketty nous dit voilà
maintenant on sait que cette promesse
n'a strictement plus aucun sens et donc
la question vertigineuse qui nous pose
c'est sur quoi bâtir notre société est
donc juste pour terminer évidemment qu à
titre personnel j'ai pas envie de payer
l'héritage évidemment qu'à titre
personnel j'ai pas envie de payer
d'impôts mais si vous réfléchissez
évidemment qu'à titre personnel quand
j'étais ado peut-être que j'aurais aimé
que l'héroïne s'asseoir en vente libre
est ce que ça aurait été bon pour moi
peut-être que sur la route j'aimerais
bien qu'ils aient pas limitations de
vitesse et j'aime vautré comme un conte
à 300 à l'heure et que je laisse ma
gamine orpheline on voit donc cette idée
de j'ai pas envie si vous réfléchissez
deux secondes
si on vous avait laissé faire ce que ce
dont vous avez envie de faire depuis
vous étiez n'est pas peut-être que vous
soyez mort on vous seriez alcoolique
vous auriez des addictions ou ce soir
est devenu complètement fou donc cette
idée c'est que pour le coup est
complètement folle de dia adama sall
j'ai pas envie et on construit la
société sur ce dont j'ai envie
la réfléchissez deux secondes de dire
depuis que vous êtes néo cons mais il ya
deux profs milliers de parents et d'amis
qui vous ont sauvé justement parce
qu'ils vont du barça faut pas faire ça
ça c'est une connerie on a besoin tous
de limites c'est littéralement vital la
société aussi elle a besoin de limites
effectivement la fiscalité c'est des
limites les plus essentiels qu'on a tous
besoin pour faire les bons choix
collectifs qui le font tous du bien à
chacun d'entre vous revenez à plusieurs
reprises c'est sur les excès salariaux
dans votre ouvrage sachs et salariaux
des années 1970 que vous opposez la plus
récente revanche de capital pour
reprendre le terme de cellules sont et
dominique pion qui désigne
l'aboutissement de multiples luttes
sociales de la fin des années 60
par exemple la hausse de 35% d'ici là ni
même si les fortes revalorise
salariale suite aux crises pétrolières
alors peut-on croire à l'avenir
et si oui comment en la mise en place
d'un entre deux donc entre revanche du
capital et excès sérieux des années 70
comme solution aux de l'égalité
salariale qui continuent de se poser
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment une question
génial bon alors j'ai fait un petit peu
d'histoire mais je l'essayé drôle le
plus intéressant possible pour qu'on
comprenne un petit peu tout ce dont on
vient parce que ça commence à dater tout
ça ça fait maintenant 50 ans les
événements comment ça veut dire se
dissiper dans notre mémoire surtout que
encore une fois un petit coucou à jean
michel blanquer
tout ces éléments essentiels ne font pas
l'objet du tronc commun qui est enseigné
aux collégiens lycéens ce qui encore une
fois est un énorme
eh ben bref dans les années soixante dix
en 1973 plus précisément qu'est ce qu'on
a
alors je les ai compris que récemment en
fait on a le premier grand choc
écologique de la période contemporaine
qui le choque les produits qu est ce que
c est le choc pétrolier c'est
intéressant parce qu'au début c'est pour
des raisons diplomatiques donc à
l'époque en là le conflit très fort
évidemment entre ils ont les pays arabes
pour simplifier très fortement par dont
des historiens et donc suite à la guerre
du kippour les pays arabes qui par
hasard sont les principaux producteurs
de pétrole veulent sanctionner les pays
occidentaux pour leur soutien réelle ou
supposée à l'état d'israël puisque
effectivement notamment les principaux
consommateurs de pétrole à l'époque sont
les états unis l'europe et aussi le
japon qui est un peu rien à faire dans
l'histoire mais qui sera touche donc que
font les pays producteurs de pétrole
il diminue très fortement la production
de pétrole
donc là le mécanisme de l'offre et de la
demande joue à plein et donc le prix du
pétrole va être quadruple on va passer
je crois à l'époque de trois dollars à
12 dollars le baril à barriques de
pétrole ses 169 litres de détroit donc
imaginez à imaginer vous vous levez ce
matin là vous allez acheter votre
baguette de pain la baguette que vous
achetiez un euro hier aujourd'hui à la 4
euros vous
un souci évidemment ce n'est pas acheter
votre baguette mais évidemment à
l'époque est encore très largement
aujourd'hui le pétrole est nécessaire et
donc toutes les entreprises voient leurs
coûts de production augmenter très
fortement corps furent les entreprises
attitude rationnelle des entreprises
augmente le prix de vente de leurs
produits
et comme tous les prix de vente des
produits augmentent on a ce qu'on
appelle l'inflation c'est-à-dire le coût
de la vie augmente très forte
on est au début des années 70 le chômage
va très fortement augmenté dans les
années qui viennent mais à l'époque le
chômage est encore faible dans un pays
comme la france le parti communiste
r des principaux partis du pays l'union
soviétique encore beaucoup de prestige
en france auprès de nombreux ouvriers
la cgt est un syndicat puissant donc les
travailleurs ont dû pour qu'est ce que
font les travailleurs très logiquement
ils disent aux patrons va écouter les
amis nous voilà tout
tout augmente c'est le fameux du tout
augmente quand je vais faire mes courses
tout est plus cher à cause effectivement
du choc pétrole donc je demande des
augmentations de salaires logique
rationnelle et là qu'est ce qui se passe
il se passe qu'en raison du rapport de
force de l'époque les salariés
obtiennent les hausses de salaires que
font les entreprises
on rappelle que dans leurs coûts de
production leurs coûts énergétiques ont
beaucoup augmenté à cause du pic du
pétrole des produits qu'elles achètent
sont eux aussi plus cher parce que eux
aussi sont plus chers à cause du pétrole
et en plus maintenant les entreprises
doivent payer des salaires plus élevés
c'est la panique
ma vraie panique du côté des entreprises
pour des très bonnes raisons donc que
font les autres mais augmente le prix de
vente de leurs produits
et donc vous voyez qu'un mécanisme qui
s'enclenche augmentation de +
revendication salariale augmentations
des salaires augmentation des coûts de
production augmentation des prix et je
peux recommencer comme ça pendant une
demi-heure mais je pense qu'on a compris
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle en économie
de la boucle prix salaires ou dans des
termes plus politique la spirale
inflationniste
effectivement si vous regardez les
chiffres de l'époque on arrive à des
taux d'inflation très important que plus
personne n'a connu ni voulu qu'à et du
caddie mois sauf si vous avez vécu dans
des pays étrangers vous avez et pas du
tout qu en france et au royaume uni
notamment que les taux d'inflation se
jouera un rôle très important dans
l'arrivée au pouvoir de malades saturées
en 69
vous avez l'inflation qui fait 10 15 %
tous les ans tous les ans imaginez que
là tout ce que vous achetez vos t-shirts
téléphone a augmenté de 10% tout vous ne
l'avez jamais vécu donc à l'époque le
problème numéro un c'est la fonction
mais ce qu'on constate quand on regarde
les chiffres de l'économie française
c'est quand la force
grand par la force des salariés va être
leur plus grande catastrophe c'est qu'en
fait à ce moment là le pouvoir des
salariés il est trop fort et donc dans
ce qu'on appelle le partage de la valeur
ajoutée c'est-à-dire le partage du
gâteau inquiet produit chaque année par
la france
la part des salariés va augmenter assez
fortement et la part des entreprises va
baisser et c'est ce que va constater le
pouvoir socialiste quand il arrivait au
pouvoir en 1981
des gens comme michel rocard ou des gens
comme jacques delors vont alerter le
pouvoir socialiste
avec ces chiffres là nous ont regardés
nous avons un nombre considérable
d'entreprises françaises qui sont au
bord de la faillite
et c'est vrai c'est totalement vrai
c'est un peu comme aujourd'hui que le
committee vous avez un problème de
faillite de très nombreuses entreprises
potentiellement et donc le fameux
tournant de la rigueur qui là encore
devrait bien enseigner à nos collégiens
et les lycéens de 1983
et justifier sur le plan économique par
quelque chose de tout à fait juste c'est
une décision que moi aussi je vous
recommande à l'époque que qui s'appelait
donc restaurer la profitabilité des
entre le problème à l'époque c'est que
les profits des entreprises si je
quitterais clairement en tant
qu'économiste de gauche en 1983 et
profits les entreprises françaises sont
trop faibles
mais ce qui va se passer par la suite
c'est que cette politique elle pas trop
bien marché
et c'est là que va naître l'expression
atroce un de modération salariale et
comme assez intéressante parce que oui
c'est comme à consommer avec modération
comme l'alcool donc c'est de dire que le
salaire c'est quelque chose de nocif de
mauvais pour la santé
la santé de l'économie donc on va
demander aux salariés de se serrer la
ceinture
ce qui va se faire très naturellement
avec le chômage de masse est-ce qu'en
le taux de chômage est déjà très élevé
ça fait déjà 10 ans que la crise
économique est là et tout simplement les
gens ne demandent plus de hausses de
salaires parce qu'ils savent qu'ils
veulent pas ne vont pas les obtenir
et parce que les gens sont rationnels et
ils savent qu'ils préfèrent garder leurs
emplois mal payés que voir la boîte
coule et ou risquer eux d'être licencié
pour qu'on embauche quelqu'un de moins
bien payés que à la place des jambes
grosso modo dans la vie issa rouhou l
orateur donc le chômage de masse les
politiques de modération salariale en
france par exemple tu avais un mécanisme
qui s'appelait la vexation automatique
qui faisaient que lorsque l'inflation et
quelle mesure et les salaires l'année
prochaine d'après augmenter
automatiquement c'est dur imaginaire
dans un pays donc effectivement
d'économie de marché
il y avait une orientation nationale sur
le niveau des salaires qui est
évidemment totalement disparu depuis
c'est justement jacques delors qui
l'appuyaient munichois bref toujours est
il que cette part des salaires dans le
pib est ce une découpe que je montre mes
étudiants qui augmentent fortement au
cours des années soixante dix couples
elle va s'effondrer au cours des années
80 et le problème c'est qu'on va plus
arriver à baisser c'est abaisser cette
baisse on peut dire à mettre fin à cette
baisse de la part des salaires dans le
gâteau national produit chaque année
notamment parce que tous les pays font
pareil c'est d'ailleurs que ce qui se
passe en france ça se passe aussi
beaucoup plus fortement même est bon moi
c'est toute ma jeunesse je n'ai pas
connu ça c'est l'époque où tous les pays
qui sont obsédés par l'anp taux
d'inflation et surtout par la
comparaison de leurs taux d'inflation
avec celui des voisins et notamment en
france
je me rappelle d'une ouverture du
journal de 20h dans les années 80 ou 90
où pour la première fois le taux
d'inflation français étaient passés en
dessous du taux allemand
si vous en avez pris notre revanche sur
la seconde guerre mondiale
c'était la fierté nationale totale lecoq
cocorico dans tous les c'était moi
débouche le champagne
je plaisante évidemment les gens sont
fontaine loyers pour les pour les grands
journalistes pour les dirigeants
s'étaient victoire fabuleuse que d'avoir
un taux d'inflation inférieur à celui de
l'allemagne toute la mythologie qui va
derrière on est enfin un peuple sérieux
organisé d'abord jean claude trichet en
france 5 elle joue un rôle fantastique
dans la diffusion de l'idée que le taux
d'inflation était ce qu'avait plus
importants au monde
c'est pour vous dire comme des choses
passent vite ça vous paraît délirant ce
que je vous raconte aujourd'hui puisque
jamais connu une inflation mais il faut
bien comprendre petit aparté notamment
que toute l'europe toutes les
institutions de l'union européenne ont
été bâties pour répondre à ce problème
qui n'existe plus depuis 40 ans qui est
l'inflation
ça c'est un des messages principaux que
je transmets mes étudiants qui conseille
pour ce grand train de rédiger leurs
mémoires
regardez toujours dans quel contexte une
loi est adoptée dans quel contexte une
institution est adopté et dit toujours
mes étudiants quel était le problème que
les gens voulaient résoudre à l'époque
quand ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont regardé
toujours ça et en fait on oublie après
pourquoi les institutions ont été créées
et on oublie que donc la lutte contre
l'inflation a été vraiment l'obsession
mais après ford c sont légitimes quand
vous aviez connu des années 70 et
dirigeants pendant des heures
bref aujourd'hui lorsqu'on allait on en
est à un niveau où il ya beaucoup de
salaires qui sont beaucoup trop faibles
tout le monde le sait moi j'ai assisté à
des émissions sur bfm ou à l'antenne
j'ai un vice-président du medef qui me
le dit oui effectivement on sait qu'on a
beaucoup nos salariés qui n'arrivent pas
à vivre décemment correctement qui sont
bien sûr au smic ce même plus cosmique
mais qui n'arrive pas à avoir le niveau
de vie moyen de notre société où la
suite me renvoie la publicité les gens
qui sont beaucoup trop mal payé mais qui
me dina qui dit à l'antenne ce que ne
dirait jamais un dirigeant du parti
socialiste vous avez un vice-président
du medef qui nous dit oui effectivement
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont trop mal
payé en france mais on ne peut pas les
augmenter à cause du chômage à cause de
la fameuse compétitivité et de l'autre
côté comme vous disiez effectivement il
ya tout un tas de ça
elle surtout de revenus qui sont
extrêmement élevés notamment dans les
professions libérales regarder les vrais
revenus par exemple de certaines
professions médicales
les radiologues par exemple qui gagne
rarement d'argent les professions
libérales
il ya une inégalité qui est très très
forte aujourd'hui en france alors
comment est-ce qu'on peut la résoudre
sur le papier de l'économie c'est simple
c'est juste demandé des bons des bons
côtés de la concurrence loyale
définition que j'aime beaucoup du plein
emploi
qu'est ce que c'est le plein emploi les
définitions du plein emploi c'est
lorsque le salarié choisi son employeur
autant que l'employeur choisi son
salarié
c'est ça le plein et si vous
réfléchissez bien vous dites qu'il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises et même de
ministre de l'économique ont pas
forcément super envie qui est le plein
emploi parce que le plein emploi c'est
la possibilité aux gens de dire à leurs
patrons battus c'est quoi comme le
faisait mais par embraser les 60
bâtiments mère mon gars eh ben je me
casse je me lève et je me casse parce
que je traverse la rue et il ya du
boulot en fasse le plein emploi
justement à pour reprendre ce que disait
tout à l'heure ça c'est la liberté c'est
la liberté des deux côtés de se choisir
comme dans un couple
elle pouvoir se quitter comme dans un
couple parce que chacun a des options
extérieur alors le champ bal demain
c'est vraiment le contraire de la
liberté aujourd'hui combien de gens
choisissent leur emploi aujourd'hui
combien de gens se rendent malade
physiquement psychologiquement dans leur
emploi mais n'arrive pas en partir parce
que pour plein de raisons aux pleins de
raisons mais notamment parce que y'a pas
mieux ailleurs ou savent pas où aller
c'est bien pour ça que la phrase
emmanuel macron a tellement fait ce
qu'on veut c'est qu'il ya plein de gens
qui ont envie de traverser la rue dallée
il est simplement enfin s'il ya rien où
il ya pire
d'accord donc sur le papier la solution
c'est comme je disais tout à l'heure
pour les retraites la solution c'est des
crèches à la solution soit aux
inégalités salariales c'est l'emploi
c'est il faut créer des millions
d'emplois
alors est-ce qu'on peut créer des
millions d'emplois oui il ya deux façons
principal et je m'arrête là je développe
passe est expliquée par claire d'auteur
et de façon principale de créer des
millions d'emplois en france c'est
d'abord la transition écologique
ça me investissements dans tout les
milliards énergies renouvelables
réhabilitation des bâtiments transports
collectifs innovation millions d'emplois
créés et la deuxième chose c'est la
réduction du temps de travail c'est à
dire qu historiquement le pouvoir des
salariés face aux entreprises mises à
part des périodes accidentelle de très
forte croissance économique
et justement michel husson que je vous
remercie d'avoir incité qui est vraiment
à nous les plus économiques favori en
france qu'elle n'est pas pas dans la
discipline
michel husson a fait beaucoup de travaux
le trouver très facilement sur son
incroyable site internet où ils montrent
que même dans les années 60 c'est un
article du sydney livre qui s'appelle
tout simplement et si la croissance ne
crée pas d'emplois et si la croissance
ne fait pas d'emploi et michel l'option
du monde que même dans les années 60 où
il y avait une croissance économique
formidable ce qui a vraiment permis
l'augmentation de l'emploi et donc
encore une fois leur rééquilibrage du
rapport de force entre les entreprises
et les salariés c'est la réduction des
dons crâne puisque la réduction tant
travail en france en particulier très
important dans ce moment là avec la
création d'abord la troisième puis de la
quatrième semaine de congés d'août donc
si vous voulez moins d'inégalités de
serial foot les plus d'emplois ok plus
d'emplois réductions de temps de travail
et transition écologique et est ce que
la solution se trouverait également sur
la croissance économique
alors je m'explique est ce que pour vous
qui êtes économiste c'est un critère
toujours pertinent aujourd'hui quelles
sont vos propositions phare pour
relancer la croissance économique qui
est qui qui n'est pas forcément en très
grande dynamique depuis de nombreuses
années dans votre ouvrage vous défendez
évidemment pas à la théorie du
ruissellement qui est dominante comme
vous le dites depuis les années 1980 et
fait intéressant j'ai trouvé vous vous
appuyez notamment sur l' ocde qui a
démontré que plus un pays connaissait de
fortes inégalités plus sa croissance
économique et est faible alors comment
expliquer ce phénomène natura vaud alors
deuxième moment publicitaire voici ma
réponse donc jean gadrey gens
viendraient adieu à la croissance
j'aimerais vraiment que tout le monde
glisse ce livre je vais vous répondre à
une demande qui est jean gadrey c'est un
vieux monsieur maintenant
de s'approcher des 80 ans un ancien prof
de lille ça monsieur extraordinaire qui
va consacrer sa vie à essayer de
meilleur monde contre les états unis au
ghana
c'est un économiste et mathématicien
statisticiens qui a fait beaucoup dans
quête de terrains dans les services dans
les supermarchés en france à l'étranger
aux états unis au japon qui se bat
depuis des décennies pour notamment quel
économiste féministe vraiment écologique
vraiment qu'ils proposent plein de
solutions qui connaît il permit à la
réalité qui est un blog sur internet il
économique où il ya des centaines de
textes que vous pouvez tous lire là
encore gratuitement et vous pouvez le
remercier vraiment du travail gratuit
qu'il apporte à tout le monde qui est
extraordinaire
pour dire les choses simplement si sans
parler du fonctionnement de la société
mais si juste la gauche allait à peu
près normalement en france ça devrait
être l'économiste le plus connu à gauche
de france parce que le travail qu'il a
fait depuis des décennies est prodigieux
avec un souci pédagogique démentiel
m'inspire énormément de lui dans ce que
je fais actuellement et donc qu'est ce
qu'il raconte jean gadrey dans ce livre
eh ben ils apportent des connaissances
et skate ses connaissances qu'est ce
qu'elles nous disent eh bien nous disent
que pour les gens qui veulent bien voir
on sait
au moins deux choses on sait qu
effectivement la croissance économique a
permis dans nos pays dans les pays
riches une augmentation sans précédent
du bien-être qu'on peut mesurer par
plein d'indicateurs que tout le monde
connaît accès à l'éducation allongement
de l'espérance de vie
confort loisirs etc et aucun doute là
dessus la deuxième chose est donc le
corollaire de ce premier résultât sic
évidemment évidemment que la croissance
économique est nécessaire pour la
l'immense majorité des habitants de la
planète qui comme nous ont envie d'avoir
le goût fort qui comme nous ont envie
d'avoir l'électricité qui comme nous
envie d'avoir des loisirs de pas crever
la dalle
là il ya aucun doute là dessus
maintenant deuxième point le problème
c'est que la croissance économique dans
ces pays pauvres elle est pas possible
sur le plan écologique
donc là on a un problème démentiel
personne n'a la solution
la troisième chose que nous dit jean
gadrey parce que c'est pas lui qui parle
comme dans mon livre par mon buzz jamais
de le rappeler dans mon livre
80% des choses qui sont apportées ce
n'est pas moi qui parle je cite des gens
bien plus fort que moi dans tous les
domaines et j'ai amplement je porte à la
connaissance du public ce que dit ces
gens là le but de moulis à me faire le
porte voix de tous les sociologues
économistes historiens qui travaille
comme des damnés depuis des décennies et
qui nous apporte des résultats qui sont
en fait très encourageant j'apporte
leurs connaissances à la portée de qui
veut bien le lien donc cadrait résume
bien aussi des travaux qui ont été faits
que certains il a fait lui-même et donc
ces travaux nous montre que notamment il
faut toujours regarder les états unis
dont on aime bien se moquer un mois
comme tout le monde mais qui sont
clairement notre avenir
à chaque fois c'est le cas sur tous les
plans de la société d'ailleurs beaucoup
plus que ce qu'on croit donc aux états
unis on sait que la croissance
économique est néfaste est la dure mais
elle est née face depuis c'est ça qui
coïncidence c'est une coïncidence mais
depuis les années 70 par comment est ce
qu'on sait pas ce qu'on regarde l'état
réel de la société il suffit d'aller aux
états unis tout le monde connaît
l'ambiance de l'importance par mon la
criminalité dans ce pays l'épidémie
d'obésité dans ce pays le mal être
général
l' isolement des gens la souffrance qui
est visible dans les cornes dans les
esprits en très grande souffrance dans
ce pays beaucoup plus qu'en france les
gens sont malheureux
tout simplement parce que effectivement
leur vie a été dissoute par la société
de marché
parce qu'effectivement ils peuvent aller
acheter une brique de lait à 3 heures du
matin ce qui est débile le font mais ils
sont hyper malheureux dans leur travail
parce qu'ils consomment de la mer
littéralement parce qu'ils sont noyés
saturé de publicité en permanence parce
qu'ils font un travail qui n'a aucun
sens
ou qu'ils savent que ça n'a aucun sens
c'est une très grande souffrance de la
jeunesse en france
moi j'ai plein plein d'étudiants qui se
battent pour décrocher des boulots dont
ils n'ont pas envie pour faire des trucs
de community manager sur des sites
internet qui servent à rien et c'est
vrai qu'ils savent ça sert à rien ils
savent que ça pollue que ça pousse à la
consommation ils n'ont pas d'autre choix
évidemment je ne revienne pas du tout la
pierre mais ça le rend comme très
malheureux parce qu'en plus on du mal à
décrocher c'est boulot là que sont bâle
pays et qui n'ont aucun sens donc de
toute évidence la société américaine va
mal et d'ailleurs jean gadrey justement
fait un très beau texte sur son blog ou
de façon très sérieuse en économistes
avec des faits il nous dit voilà les
états unis sont un pays qui envoie deux
tiers mondisation donc sur le plan de ce
qu'on appelle la santé social c'est
derrière un peu moins la qualité de la
vie il est maintenant clairement établie
depuis des années déjà à que la
croissance économique effectivement elle
est possible aux états unis mais elle
est simplement néfastes
les gens sont plus malheureux les gens
vivent plus mal et d'ailleurs vous savez
l'espérance de vie a commencé à diminuer
aux états unis depuis plusieurs années
gadret notamment fait un encadré dans ce
livre dans ce livre adieu à la
croissance sur la comparaison du système
de santé
ça c'est très intéressant c'est à dire
que imaginé voilà vous allez chez votre
médecin
quand vous allez chez votre médecin
aujourd'hui la tout à l'heure vous payez
mettons 20 euros quand il ya une réforme
de la santé tout la santé est privatisée
en france comme aux états unis
totalement très très largement vous
retournez chez votre médecin vous avez
la même maladie il vous prescrit des
médicaments vous a retourné la semaine
prochaine maintenant c'est 200 euros
comme je lé connue aux etats-unis quand
j'ai vu que c'était fini pour nous ok
maintenant la consulter deux s'en vont
parce que votre médecin a besoin de
s'acheter un troisième 4 4 les deux
premiers vont pas assez vite
ok vous payer 200 euros on est d'accord
que dans la réalité rien n'a changé et
bat pour les statisticiens ya de la
croissance économique
quand vous passez de 20 euros la
consultation à 200 euros la consultation
il ya eu effectivement il ya bien eu 180
euros de valeur ajoutée et qu'est ce que
c'est que le pib
et qu'est ce que c'est que la croissance
du produit intérieur brut c'est la somme
des valeurs ajoutées créés par les
entreprises
donc lorsque votre médecin il vous
demande 200 euros plutôt que 20 euros
eh bien le pib a augmenté de 180 et
voyez bien que la production de santé
n'a pas augmenté la production santé est
la même et donc là vous voyez qu'on
arrive un truc vertigineuse c'est que
qu'est-ce qu'on mesure avec nos amis cap
donc oui on peut faire de la croissance
économique
mais oui elle est néfaste dans nos pays
et surtout à ce que nous montre tous les
travaux notamment le jour du dépassement
que nous avons déjà atteint 1 pour la
france déjà atteint le jour du
dépassement
en france il ya quelques jours il ya eu
un énorme incendie près de marseille
deux mois d'avril n'est pas au mois de
juillet et on est déjà dans la
sécheresse à marseille tous les ans en
france la majorité des départements
bandeau donc la croissance de la
consommation de matières la croissance
de la consommation d'énergie la
croissance la consommation de ressources
naturelles
on le sait elle est déjà à aussi on est
déjà on tape déjà dans des réserves qui
ne sont pas renouvelables
en tout cas qui sont pas renouvelables
avant des millions d'amis qui en fait ne
sont pas renouvelables
pour ce qui nous concerne nous
l'humanité donc la croissance économique
on peut faire tous les débats qu'on veut
là on peut parler vous voyez là vous et
moi on est très pollué et je le dis tout
le temps pardon mais cette idée que là
ce qui se passe ça serait immatériel
c'est comme à mourir de rien parce que
là je suis en train de parler machine
qui consomment de l'énergie qui est
branché sur l'électricité il ya des
ondes qui circulent moi même d'ailleurs
chantin de consommer de l'énergie un jeu
je me fatigue quand j'avais besoin
ensuite reconstitué ma force d'autres
comme dirait qu'un max vous voyez que
tout notre imaginaire il faut c'est à
dire que l'idée de la croissance
économique c'est impossible sur le plan
intérieur
l'idée qui aurait un développement des
activités immatérielles est totalement
fausse
regardez moi je compare toujours
l'intérieur de ma maison avec
l'intérieur de chez mes parents au même
âge
il y avait beaucoup moins d'objets y
avait pas de téléphone portable
il y avait un téléphone fixe dans la
maison il y avait une télé n'y avait pas
d'ordi il n'ya pas d'objets qui ont été
supprimés nous avons de plus en plus
d'objets partout et qui sont en plus
connectés donc il pouffe de l'énergie
c'est génial
donc cette idée je sais pas comment les
publicitaires ont réussi à tous nous
mettre dans l'idée que nous c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'immatériel
alors que nos maisons sont toujours plus
truffé d'objets d'écran qui en plus donc
au consommer de l'énergie poids de
produits qui en général bien de l'autre
bout de la planète et qui en plus
consomment de l'énergie en permanence
qui est produite elle aussi
matériellement puisqu'il repose sur
l'électricité
cette idée que nous soyons nous avons du
matériel là aussi pardon mais il faut se
réveiller
c'est une absurdité totale le voit
croissance impossible croissance
néfastes dans les pays riches croissance
impossible actions de la planète ça
c'est sûr les croissances nécessaires
dans les pays pauvres où habite la
majorité des habitants vous avez trois
heures bon courage pour résoudre cette
équation antilles
alors merci beaucoup pour cette réponse
ferait taille et moi j'aimerais aborder
à un autre point que vous abordez en
effet largement dans votre dernier
ouvrage qui est la question du salaire
lui-même alors que ce soit à l'échelle
nationale comme européenne
vous êtes dans l attaché à dépeindre les
avantages et les inconvénients d'une
telle mesure notamment et surtout face à
l'emploi alors selon vous comment
et doit-on en fait mettre en place un
salaire minimum commun en europe
en considérant l'hétérogénéité des
profils économiques des pays membres oui
alors l'eau donc là qu'on se dit pour
une fois je vous répond directement
évidemment qu'il faut le mettre en place
évidemment la hausse il faut savoir de
quoi on parle donc là pas de faux débats
sérieux s'énerver il s'agit pas d'avoir
le même salaire mensuel
en france et en pologne évidemment où en
france et ensuite il s'agit d'avoir le
même salaire minimum en pourcentage de
ce qu'on appelle le salaire médian ou
qu'est ce que c'est que le salaire
médian
c'est vous voyez si je prends tous les
gens qui ont un salaire en france je les
aligne le long d'un mur et je de celle
de celle qui gagnera à celui à celui qui
gagne le plus voir beaucoup plus de
femmes au début de la distribution
beaucoup plus d'hommes à la fin la
distribution est aussi beaucoup plus
d'hommes blancs évidemment est plutôt de
montage à la fin de la distribution donc
j'aligne sur le mur la totalité des gens
qui travaillent en france en fonction de
leur salaire je prends la personne du
milieu je lui demande combien il gagne
c'est ça le salaire médian et donc le
salaire médian en france à peu près de
1700 euros par an donc en france pour un
travail à temps plein il ya beaucoup de
gens qui soient à temps partiel pour un
travail à temps que le salaire médian en
france ses 1700 bull si vous gagnez plus
de 1700 euros par mois vous êtes dans la
moitié du pays qui gagne le plus
d'argent et donc l'idée ce serait
d'avoir un salaire minimum qui soit
fixée en fonction du salaire médian de
chaque pays par exemple 60%
donc ça ça paraît très faciles à adopter
alors ce qu'on peut dire tout de suite
c'est que les salaires ne sont pas une
compétence de l'union européenne il est
strictement impossible pour l'union
européenne d'imposer quoi que ce soit
concernant le niveau des salaires à quel
pays que ce soit
et d'autre part sur le plan politique
malheureusement c'est quasiment
impossible que ce salaire donc disons ce
salaire minimum européen national enfin
wife retrouver un nombre pour paraître
et de confusion ce salaire de référence
ce salaire décent ou ce salaire de vie
comme les anglo saxons j'aime bien cette
expression d appeler ça le living wedge
le salaire qui permet de vivre ne sera à
peu près aucune chance d'être adopté
donc d'abord parce qu'il ya pas mal
d'états qui sont opposés et en fait la
législation dans la réalité dans l'union
européenne
elle n'est pas faite je rappelle que la
commission européenne
c'est un truc très bizarre qui est à la
fois qui a le monopole de l'initiative
législative en europe mais qu'ils
n'adoptent pas et doit européenne a les
lois européennes
en fait elles sont adoptées de façon
conjointe par le parlement européen et
par le conseil et le conseil réunit les
états membres bref dans la réalité si
les taxes et les états membres qui
décident comme on l'a vu récemment la
dernière exemple très claire de ça c'est
le plan de relance qui a été adoptée
adopté sur le principe à l'été dernier
mais qui n'a toujours pas été ratifiés
et contre lequel la cour de karlsruhe en
allemagne la bayard de faire un recours
la semaine dernière le plan de relance
européen tout on a vu dans la presse a
été décidée par les états donc des
vraies initiatives législatives de
l'union européenne à sont décidés quasi
totalité par les états
surtout quand ça concerne des affaires
aussi sensibles que le salaire et le
salaire ni bref il faudrait l'unanimité
des états et aucune chance que ça
l'autre truc qui est plus marrant même
si c'est aussi désespérant c'est qu'en
fait qu à pas mal de syndicats qui sont
opposés à ça pour des raisons
philosophie profonde et je trouve très
intéressante qui sont très attachés à ce
qu'on appelle l'autonomie des salaires
et même ce qu'on appelait en allemand la
tarif autonomie tarifs oscillent au sens
de salaire le salaire est un prix et
donc dans des pays aussi différents que
l'italie par exemple la suède
les syndicats refusent que le salaire
minimum soit fixé par l'état par la
puissance publique pour eux ça doit
relever du dialogue social et donc des
pays aussi avancer parce que je rappelle
que les pays les plus avancés du monde
ce n'est pas la france
ce candidat donc des pays scandinaves
sont
même qu'ils sont gouvernés par la gauche
ou des raisons de fonctionnement du
dialogue social national sont opposés à
ce qu'est une initiative au niveau de
l'union européenne en matière de salaire
minimum en tout cas c'est la situation
il ya peu de chances que ça arrive
pour des raisons politiques ou des
raisons philosophiques profonds
respectable très intéressante mais en
tout cas pas pour des raisons
économiques
et ça effectivement c'est une des
chouettes découverte que j'ai fait et en
écrivant ce livre c'est que moi quand
j'étais étudiant il y avait un consensus
des économistes y compris de nombreux
économistes de gauche contre la hausse
du salaire minimum et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ce consensus ne
découlait aucunement de travaux
empiriques
absolument pas ce consensus découlait
directement et à 100% du modèle
théorique qui est très simple qui est
encore une fois le fameux modèle de
l'offre et de la demande qui est de dire
le salaire c'est un coût pour les
entreprises
si vous augmentez le salaire minimum et
bien les entreprises ont embauché - le
monde au limiter la hausse de leur masse
salariale
donc ce qu'on appelle nous dans notre
jargon la demande de travail
la demande de travail qui est exprimée
par les entreprises sur le soi-disant
marché du travail expression que je
déteste la demande de travail va baisser
et donc vous allez avoir du chômage et
donc ce qui est marrant c'est que les
économistes ça c'est très très important
à comprendre les économies du monde en
caisse avait savait que le salaire
minimum était néfaste à l'emploi le seul
problème c'est qu'il le savait pour des
raisons théoriques et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ensuite il s'est passé que
le salaire minimum a été créée ces
dernières décennies dans des pays où il
n'existait pas au royaume uni puis en
allemagne
il a d'abord été fixé de façon
pragmatique à des niveaux très bas à
cause notamment de ses travaux
d'économistes
et il ya eu des commissions notamment la
lampe est que messieurs au royaume uni
la commission sur les bas salaires qui a
fait un travail prodigieux très très
fins d'observation des conséquences de
l'observation du l'introduction par
monde le salaire minimum y compris dans
des secteurs où on sait effectivement
plus coût du travail très important
comme la sécurité comme la restauration
comme l'hôtellerie dont sept du coût du
travail effectivement être très
important parce que ces activités qui
dans ce qu'elles produisent
le coût du travail est très aisé si
renault le coût du travail on s'en fout
ce qu'il ya quasiment que des robots
dont les usines
donc c'est pas vrai coût du travail les
déterminants dans un restaurant ça reste
des activités manuelles
le coût du travail cdt rne qu'est ce que
montrent ces enquêtes
pas d'effets négatifs du ca d'hermine
qu'est ce qui se passe au royaume uni il
augmente
un petit peu le salaire minimum on sert
des effets négatifs toujours pas il
augmente encore un petit peu un petit
peu pareil en allemagne donc ce que
savait mes collègues ce que savaient les
grands professeurs d'économie du monde
entier de droite comme de gauche
le fait que le salaire minimum était
néfaste à l'emploi eh bien c'était fou
les mecs moi jamais reconnaître s'était
planté mais c'est quand même un gros
souci et en plus on voit qu évidemment
il ya des effets positifs très
intéressant du salaire minimum qu'on
observe notamment aux états unis
j'ai fait un longue article là dessus
sur le site internet ird économique
puisque le salaire minimum varie selon
les états américains et on voit que le
premier effet de l'introduction du
salaire minimum qui avait proposé à
bernie sanders qui avait promis joe
biden et auquel en tout cas il a
malheureusement déjà renoncé du fait
c'est pas du tout ces infos de
l'opposition au congrès américain dans
les états américains comme la californie
ou salaire minimum a été beaucoup
augmenté qu'est ce qu'on constate
on constate que les gens travaillent
beaucoup moins parce qu aux états-unis
en france il ya beaucoup de gens qui
vous disent qu'ils travaillent 70 heures
par semaine notamment chez les cadres
bon c'est des gens qui sont pas du tout
soixante dix heures et qui sont assis
sur leurs fesses la plupart de leurs
journées les faire des emails des
réunions etc
aux états unis vous avez des gens qui
travaillent 70 heures par semaine mais
vraiment qu'ils sont vigile qui sont
caissières qui sont femme de ménage qui
son aide soignante qui sont livreur qui
font les travaux physiques debout toute
la journée le boss vraiment 70 heures
par semaine parce qu'ils ont deux
boulots parce qu'ils ont trois boulots
parce qu'avec leurs salaires misérables
le salaire minimum fédéral aux états
unis s'avèrent totalement de misère vous
êtes extrêmement pauvre si vous ne
toucher que ça extrêmement bas lorsque
le salaire minimum augmente qu'est ce
qu'ils font il travaille moi ils ne
travaillent plus que 3000 de guillemets
60 heures par semaine au lieu de 70 et
donc ils sont moins fatigués et donc
qu'ils soient en meilleure santé et donc
on constate quand même moins de violence
conjugale que les parents s'occupent
mieux de leurs enfants arrivent mieux
alors faire leurs devoirs donc les gains
pour la société de l'augmentation du
salaire minimum lorsqu'il est très très
très bas comme aux états unis sont
conciliables
en allemagne aussi on s'est rendu compte
que qu'est ce qui se passe quand vous
introduisez salaire minimum
eh bien il ya tout un tas de boulot de
merde qui ne sont plus rentables et donc
ces boulots disparaissent et c'est tant
mieux et les entreprises sont obligées
de mieux former leurs salariés pour les
rendre plus productif parce qu'elle leur
coûte plus cher et c'est tant mieux et c
est donc ça va tellement un pardon cas
maintenant pour les gens honnêtes il y
en a quand même par nous même parmi les
économistes
quasiment un nouveau consensus qui
s'oppose à celui donc qui existaient il
ya vingt ans en faveur du salaire
minimum dont c'est tous les travaux je
cite dans mon livre est une revue de la
littérature qui a été fait par un prof
anglais de la london school au ricoh qui
montrent que les effets bénéfiques
puisque à la porte
très largement sur ses potentiels effets
négatifs alors tout ça pour quoi en fait
alors faites ce résultat il est évident
est ce que le cdr minimum il est très
bon dans tous ces pays que ce soit en
france même ce que le proposer aux états
unis où personne ne propose que c'est
terminé même soit 20 euros par mois
donc en fait c'est évident que le
salaire minimum il est bénéfique et
c'est bien évident qu'il est beaucoup
trop bas et que tous les ministres tous
mes chers collègues économistes
fonctionnaires qui hurlent contre la
hausse du salaire minimum
ils voudraient pas vivre au salaire
minimum il ne pourrait pas vivre c'est
le minimum
il pourrait même pas vivre avec le trip
du salaire minimum ils ne souhaitent pas
que leurs enfants aient un emploi payé
au salaire minimum pourquoi est ce que
c'est bon pour les autres c'est pas bon
pour eux oui ça c'est un vrai problème
voilà alors je l'aï su répondre à votre
question j'aurais vu est ce que je peux
faire encore de petits encarts
publicitaires ont pas et vous faites
donc une lecture vraiment positive que
je vous conseille un les amis pour vivre
heureux vivons ego kate pickett richard
wilkinson le plus grand livre un livre
pour avoir la patate et ils vous
montrent que si on met en place les bons
systèmes d'éducation de coopération dès
l'enfance on règle tous les prêtres de
société et que les inégalités en tout le
monde malheureux un bijou absolu à lire
et à offrir à tous vos ébats et enfin
pour mes amis de gauche par rapport à
2022 le livre à lire bernard maris ce
plaidoyer impossible pour les
socialistes le livre le plus intime de
bernard marc à nice il parle de sa
jeunesse il parle de son père il parle
de jaurès n'est pas connu évidemment il
parle de proudhon seine-et-marne fiches
de lecture sur les grands penseurs de
gauche depuis deux siècles
c'est plein de réflexions sur la
coopération sur la république sur
l'égalité c'est absolument prodigieux
c'est hyper c'est hyper mots voilà donc
le plus beau texte de banat maryse son
plus personnel et aussi sont plus
politiques c'est celui-là donc un petit
coucou aux candidats de 2022 qui qui
nous regardent les amis lisez ça et y
raison de bonnes leçons s'il vous plaît
merci merci beaucoup pour ses conseils
de lecture qui donneront de la matière à
lire à nous à nos auditeurs
alors si vous me le permettez je vais
revenir sur un auteur que vous avez
cités en début d'entrevue qui est
évidemment karl marx et je vais
notamment évoqué sa principale notion
qui est la lutte des classes vous
expliquez dans votre livre que les très
riches perçoivent des profits à la fois
sur les entreprises qu'ils dirigent
les loyers des logements dont ils sont
propriétaires les intérêts de leurs
placements
les dividendes de leurs actions en
résumé ce qu'on peut appeler du capital
qui offrent un rendement alors que pour
grosso modo les 80% de la population
restante
elle vit d'abord de son travail et donc
elle a besoin que l'économie soit en
croissance pour
son revenu augmente alors le problème
que vous pointez c'est que le rendement
du capital est plus élevé que la
croissance de l'économie
alors qu'en parallèle les revenus des
très riches s'accroissent sans
nécessairement de lien avec leur travail
et s
au final une lutte des classes qui n'a
jamais cessé
alors pour partir de la fin de votre
question il ya une citation que j'aime
beaucoup qui est très célèbre qui d'un
milliardaire américain qui me dit il ya
effectivement une lutte des classes et
c'est ma classe qui a gagné son nom
m'échappe évidemment ça met plus grands
médias américains qui est célèbre pour
son fonds de fonds de placement qui gère
depuis maintenant des décennies
savourez venir sa part ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il est encore sur notre servent
si on observe les choses
ce qui est vrai c'est que par rapport à
effectivement en disant aux années
soixante dix où 80 il ya une dissolution
de la classe ouvrir de façon empirique
de façon humaine de façon géographie
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui le livreur
là tout à l'heure qui va m'apporter le
truc que j'ai commandé sur internet
la femme qui est vendeuse dans un
magasin dans un dans un centre
commercial
les personnes qui font ménage les
chauffeurs routiers les gens qui sont
dans les entrepôts des magasiniers
tous ces gens là ils ont des revenus
très proches ils ont des difficultés
très proches dans le travail
ils ont les des intérêts économiques et
politiques très proches mais ces gens là
ils se connaissent pas ils se
connaissent pas et sont pas au même
endroit
ils travaillent pas ensemble et en fait
ça c'est très simple et ça change tout
il y avait une phrase qu'on disait bon
sens d'ailleurs été mal compris mais une
fameuse phrase je crois qui avait été
dit dans les années 70 on disait il ne
faut pas désespérer billancourt
billancourt c'était la grande usine
renault c'était une des plus grandes
usines de france sur l'île seguin à
boulogne-billancourt
je crois que c'était jean paul sartre
qu'avait dit il ne faut pas désespérer
billancourt
j'avais regardé en fait ce qu'il disait
en fait ce qui voulait dire c'est très
cynique en fait il disait il faut pas
dire la vérité aux ouvriers sur la
réalité sociale en fait c'était une
mesure d'ordre social mais que cette
expression est telle que j'ai compris
c'est elle qu'il est généralement
compris c'est de dire faut pas
désespérer billancourt s'il faut
augmenter les salaires des ouvriers pour
pas qu'ils se révoltent où qu'ils
aillent bien
effectivement habillé en cours à
l'époque vous aviez des milliers des
milliers de gens qui étaient au même
endroit qu'ils pouvaient se parler et la
régie renault à l'époque quand c'est
encore une entreprise publique était
défendue comme une vitrine sociale n
avait été en avance par exemple
notamment sur l'introduction de la
quatrième semaine de congés payés qui a
été introduite chez renault avant d'être
généralisé au niveau national bref les
gens se connaissaient et en plus c'est
très important comme x y avait la
puissance de la cgt il y avait la
puissance du parti communiste il y avait
le prestige de l'union soviétique
je ne dis pas du tout ça pour les
défendre je dis ça comme scientifique en
tant que fait il y avait des faits
sociaux massifs et tout s'est fait en
dix par et
il est certain même si là aussi encore
une fois ce n'est pas enseigné que dans
les processus d'externalisation qui ont
été décidées par les grandes entreprises
à partir des années 70 quand il décide
et pour plusieurs raisons
une des raisons assumer objective et est
racontée par les dirigeants à l'époque
c'était de casser ces collectifs ou et
si vous reprenez la même entreprise
renault aujourd'hui comment est-ce
qu'elle fonctionne les usines renault
assemble en fait des produits quasiment
finie elle travaille avec des centaines
de fournisseurs
il ya 40 ans est le fournisseur il
appartenait à renault tout était fait
sur rhône où une en tout cas la plus
grande partie de la voiture était fait
chaud aujourd'hui ses fournisseurs et
ils sont en concurrence
ils sont en couple aux donc les mêmes
ouvriers ou si vous voulez les fils et
les petits-fils des filles et les
petites filles de ses ouvriers d'il ya
quarante ans de chez renault qui font
voiliers qui participent au même
processus productif d'un point de vue
matériel sont dans une situation
économique dans une situation sociale
des situations humaines psychologie qui
m'arrive à moi c'est que sans même que
leur patron et à leurs dires ils savent
que pour préserver le contrat avec
renault pour décrocher le prochain
contrat de la prochaine voiture il faut
battre les fournisseurs évidemment
situés en france mais évidemment si tu
es aujourd'hui sur la planète entière
avec lesquels ils sont en concurrence
donc vous avez pour prendre une image
atroce dans le bas de la société ouvrier
chez les employés des gens qui encore
une fois ont les mêmes besoins en termes
d'emploi de stabilité de l'emploi en
terme de hausse de salaires en termes de
qualité des services publics
et ces gens là ils représentent en fait
à peu près la moitié de la population
française et c'est l'électorat
voilà populaire c'est les gens qui
auraient besoin d'un gouvernement qui
les protège qui garantissent ce qui est
très loin d'être le cas aujourd'hui
évidemment le plein emploi des bons
salaires une éducation vraiment gratuite
une santé vraiment tendu donc ce qui est
curieux c'est qu'on a encore une fois
une part très importante de la
population et qui évidemment c'est très
fortement accrue avec la crise sanitaire
absolument terrible que nous vivons
depuis plus d'un an maintenant
et donc ces gens là on pourrait penser
qu'ils sont la cible naturelle d'un
programme économique et social de
progrès simple que pourraient partager
beaucoup de gens de gauche comme de
droite simplement humaniste pour que les
gens puissent vivre décemment dans notre
pays mais dans la réalité
voilà ces gens là ils ne se connaissent
pas et ils ont encore une fois si on
prend l'exemple des fournisseurs de
renault des intérêts divergents et même
des intérêts clairement opposés et ils
le savent c'est pour ça notamment quand
on regarde les électorats
on voit par exemple que la france a
soumises la france a soumis ce n'est pas
évidemment le premier vote ouvrier et de
très loin parce que notamment les
ouvriers savent que lorsque la france
insoumise propose de fortement augmenter
le salaire minimum
évidemment que ces ouvriers le souhaite
mais évidemment que ces ouvriers savent
que c'est strictement impossible parce
que dans les petites entreprises dans
lesquelles ils travaillent ils voient
que même leur patron cool touche 2000
2500 euros par mois et ils savent bien
qu'un smic à 1500 euros par voie couleur
et leur boîte
ils le savent donc dans les rectorats de
la france a souri cela est plutôt des
fonctionnaires mal pays qui sont
sensibles au discours sur la disparition
de l'état juste titre l'effondrement des
services publics et vous n'avez pas un
électorat ouvrier dont on sait à
respectivement que le premier
comportement politique c'est
l'abstention c'est un des problèmes
majeurs de notre démocratie est le 2ème
comportement politique c'est le vote
pour le rassemblement national qui
d'ailleurs aussi touche de plus en plus
la jeunesse et des articles sont sortis
récemment là d'ssus absolument
terrifiant bref de l'autre côté de la
société si on peut dire en eau comme
aurait peut-être dit pierre bourdieu le
sociologue
vous avez des gens qui par contre eux se
connaissent et dont les intérêts sont
objectivement les mêmes c'est à dire là
maintenant évidemment ça devient un tout
petit peu trop voyant et ça devient très
très gênant pour tout le monde
on a bien compris avec la majorité
actuelle que les ministres les grands
patrons les journalistes des grandes
chaînes
son ami se connaissent se tutoient
sortent ensemble ont des relations
amicales amoureuses et c'est un tout
petit peu trop évident
avec les allers retours entre le privé
et le public de tout un tas de ministres
encore brune poirson l'acquis annoncé
qu'elle quittait la vie politique pour
aller gagner dix fois plus dans le
groupe accor même groupe accor qui
martyrise de façon hallucinante les
femmes de ménage qui sont en lutte
depuis deux ans et qui demandent je
crois ou d'indemnités je crois de 7 ou 8
euros par jour pour pouvoir manger à
midi qu'il en ait pas de local où manger
à midi qui ont des travaux extrêmement
fatigant et donc là une violence en a
résumé lors la promo de lutte des
classes qui est terrible donc on a sept
femmes ou alors en pleine santé qui a
une vie facile brut par son qui va les
occuper un emploi totalement inutile
dans une des plus grands groupes
capitalistes français ou accord qui ait
connue depuis toujours pour martyriser
de façon très très forte
les femmes de ménage qui travaille chez
lui qui sont vraiment payé assez
rapidement de misère ça devrait faire
l'ouverture du vingt heures et ça ne
fera pas évidemment et de l'autre côté
cette fable pour une poirson et qui va
être responsable demande du
développement durable du pipeau intégral
qui est là pour son carnet d'adressés
pour les relations publiques et qui va
gagner peut-être dix fois vingt fois
tous les mois ce que gagnent ces femmes
de ménage pour un travail beaucoup plus
difficile et lui pour le coup a
véritablement utile à la société
donc vous voyez on a ce problème là on a
des groupes sociaux qui ont des intérêts
différents et simplement le groupe duo
de la société fonctionne bien de façon
harmonieuse et de plus en plus de plus
en plus fluide de plus en plus voyante
avec des allers-retours personnel et
encore une fois et pour le coup leurs
intérêts sont les mêmes voilà j'ai
retrouvé mon du milliardaire américain
pardon si warren buffett
warren buffett du fonds berkshire qui
est un des plus grands fonds qui est un
des génies de la finance
voilà donc c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça la
difficulté et je voudrais juste rappeler
à 7,8 pour répondre à votre question de
façon indirecte que les salaires sont
plus élevés dans l'industrie que dans
les services à des drames de notre
soi-disant société de services déjà
papier tout à l'heure qui était très
très matérielle c'est que on a une image
négative des usines de ça pollue etc
ce qui est vrai mais les services pour
lui aussi parfois plus en forme qu'à
droite et cédric c'est dans l'industrie
convient beaucoup mieux
c'est l'industrie qui a créé une classe
moyenne et alors là j'ai pas les
réponses malheureusement mais faudrait
déjà commencer à se poser les bonnes
questions si on veut restaurer la
confiance dans l'avenir si on veut
restaurer un minimum de fonctionnement
de notre société
il faut absolument au bâtir la base de
tout ça c'est de rebâtir une industrie
performante puissance ça devrait être
une des priorités de nos dirigeants
merci beaucoup alors dans cette entrevue
on a pu parler donc de l'une des classes
on vient d'en parler on a plus parlé
aussi vous avez pu évoquer
l'automatisation des processus
industriels les récents progrès des
technologies de l'information la
communication
darche des éléments que vous mettez en
lien dans votre livre comme causes
majeures de l'effondrement de la classe
moyenne que veut qualifier elle d'
essentiel à notre démocratie
alors mes murs abonnement une question
quelles caractéristiques propres à la
classe moyenne en fonte pour vous un
élément essentiel au bon fonctionnement
démocratique
alors là aussi on regarde de façon
scientifique la classe moyenne elle est
c'est un des piliers de la démocratie
avec bien d'autres comme le
fonctionnement la justice indépendance
de la presse d'éducation la classe
moyenne elle est très intéressante parce
qu'elle est conservatrice
je dirai au bon sens du terme c'est à
dire que la classe moyenne quand elles
quand elles existent quand elle est
importante quand elle pas bien ben voilà
il est en fonction elle est enfin leur
faveur par don de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler une économie mixte acquis et
l'accès dans laquelle nous vivons en
france c'est à dire avec des entreprises
privées pour le public et tout ça c'est
qu'il y plus doux al'inverse ce que
l'histoire nous a appris et la raison
pour laquelle la crise de 1929 elle est
enseignée au lycée
même si elle est très mal enseignée
parce qu'on nous dit pas tout simplement
aux lycéens
pourquoi elle est enseignée pourquoi ce
qu'elle est enseignée la crise de 1929
parce que la crise de 1929 ça a été la
démonstration empirique que
l'effondrement la classe moyenne
pouvaient mener à la destruction de la
démocratie quand vous avez des gens de
menad john maynard keynes à l'eau
keynes soi-disant théorie star de l'état
mais en fait des oris hier de l'économie
de marché et surtout théoriciens des
entreprises qu'est ce que voit qu'un ce
qui à 50 ans à peu près à l'époque au
début des années 30 avec la crise de
qu'est ce qu'il voit qu est-ce qui
comprend tout est bio cloud il comprend
que lorsque vous avez une crise
boursière donc celle d'octobre 1929 aux
états unis qui se diffuse à l'ensemble
de la planète
lorsque vous avez comme aux etats-unis
de milliers de banques qui ferment des
banques qui font faillite des gens qui
perdent toutes leurs économies
des gens qui perdent leur emploi à une
époque où il n'y a pas d'assurance
chômage
il n'y a pas de sécurité sociale c'est
justement roosevelt qui va créer tout ça
après aux états unis que la crise se
diffuse à l'ensemble du monde que vous
avez en allemagne notamment des millions
et des millions de gens qui perdent leur
emploi parce que suite à la crise de
1929 que font les dirigeants ils
obéissent justement à la doctrine
économique et donc qu'est ce qu'ils font
et augmente les impôts ils baissent les
dépenses sociales dont qu'ils accra
blues aggrave la crise c'est comme ce
qui s'est passé en grèce il ya quelques
années dans toutes ces crises le pire
c'est toujours la réaction politique
sait jamais la crise économique
c'est comme la crise financière en
argentine c'est bernard et crise
économique c'est terrible mais le pire
c'est toujours les mauvaises réactions
politiques aux crises tôt qu'en
allemagne
le chancelier brüning qui est à fond
pour l'austérité a comme pelard de
dirigeants aujourd'hui ce chancelier va
prendre les pierres des signes il va
aggraver très fortement la crise
économique
on a aujourd'hui des travaux d'histoire
économique qui lui montrent que là où
les politiques d'austérité ont été les
plus fortes en allemagne c'est là où le
vote en faveur du parti national
socialiste du parti nazi ont été les
plus fortes
qu'est ce qui se passe à ce moment là
vous allez des gens qui ont faim qui
sont très bons qu'est ce qu'ils veulent
ils veulent pouvoir se nourrir veulent
pouvoir nourrir leurs enfants
donc ça c'est ce qu'on peut appeler la
demande politique leur fasse qu'est-ce
que vous avez vous avez une offre
politique
vous avez un homme qui pour plein
d'autres raisons tout le monde comprend
bien j'espère de simplifier à outrance
donc et adolf hitler
quelle est la première promesse d'hitler
c'est le plein emploi
c'est le plein emploi et donc hitler qui
n'a pas été élu je le rappelle qui a été
nommé à la tête de l'état suite à la
victoire de son parti aux élections
législatives qui est nommé chancelier
donc hitler va réaliser cette promesse
très rapidement il va mettre en place
des grands travaux c'est la fameuse
autoroute allemand il va faire une
course à l'armement donc hitler va
résoudre le principal problème des
allemands à l'époque qui est la misère
qui est la faim en donnant du travail
avec une économie administrée
donc je reviens qu'est-ce qu'elle suède
en angleterre il voit arriver tout ça
qu'est ce qui nous dit qu'est ce qui
nous dit ce sont les entreprises qui
créent les emplois
ce soit l'entreprise qui fait les
emplois et même midi ce sont les
entrepreneurs mais qu'elles sont dix
entrepreneurs c'est des êtres humains et
ils ont des humeurs
ils ont des anticipations mais qu'est ce
que c'est qu'une anticipation de
l'économie c'est une croyance que vous
avez par rapport à l'avenir mais qui
vous fait agir et qui vous fait agir
aujourd'hui c'est ça une anticipation
dès que c'est comme c'est comme dans aux
sports voyez quand émile ntamack qui
franchit la ligne davantage antoine
dupont il est déjà à l'intérieur pour
qu'il lui fasse la remise intérieure
parce que du coup il a anticipé ce que
j'ai fait un bac d'eau quand dupont
anticipe ce que l'affairé est un mec il
se bouge et se bougent vite et c'est
pour ça qu'il est là et qu'après wifi
l'année c'est donc anticiper en économie
que dans le sport c'est agir c'est agir
et c'est agir tout de suite donc qu'ils
nous dit suivant ce que les
entrepreneurs anticipent de l'avenir ils
agissent soit ils créent de l'emploi
soit ils licencient et qu'elle nous dit
c'est ça le plus grand message de keynes
qui malheureusement là aussi est très
mal enseignée caisse nous dit les gens
agissent au mieux leurs intérêts mais
dans une situation de crise lorsque
chacun agit au mieux de ses intérêts
c'est le pire qui se produit
hawkins nous dit encore une fois il
observe ivy sa vie l'effondrement de
l'économie
ivy l'effondrement de la société de la
démocratie voire la montée des
dictatures
il faut à l'avenir parce que c'est un
génie le mec est donc être si nous dit
en situation de crise encore une fois il
n'ya pas la sécurité sociale à l'époque
y'a pas les banques centrales qui
rachète les dettes publiques aujourd'hui
les banques centrales sont privées la
banque de france est une institution
privée à son origine été nationalisées
ou en 1936 par le front populaire en
partie donc qu'elles sont dits dans une
situation de crise que font les
entreprises comme elles font aujourd'hui
elles licencient
elles baissent les salaires etc et nous
dit elle sont raison c'est ce qu'elles
ont de mieux à faire
mais évidemment si vous licencier tout
le monde on n'avait plus le client et
donc l'entreprise d'un côté elle va
licencier aussi parce que vous avez
licenciés vos propres salariés qui
étaient ses clients la boulangerie va
fermer le coiffeur va fermer le
supermarché va fermer l usine va fermer
tout faire déjà quand on regarde
mouvement des gilets jaunes à des
prédicteurs de la mobilisation des
gilets jaunes dans les différents
villages c'est justement la fermeture
non pas des services publics mais des
derniers commerces
c'est lorsque les derniers commerces
ferment que la mobilisation en faveur
des gilet jaune a été la plus forte
donc est ce nous dit en situation de
crise chacun agit au mieux de ses
intérêts mais ce faisant chacun jouant
contre l'intérêt collectif et donc
contre son intérêt individuel et c'est
la même chose du côté des individus
aujourd'hui en france tous les gens qui
le peuvent épargner et quand vous
épargne évidemment vous ne consommez pas
et donc vous détruisez là aussi des
emplois donc aujourd'hui en france comme
dans les années 30
la réaction de l'économie privée du côté
des entreprises comme des individus
c'est de prendre des décisions qui sont
les meilleurs pour chacun mais qui sont
les pires pour tout le monde et qui donc
sont les pires pour chacun parce que si
c'est le pire pour tout le monde c'est
aussi le pire pour chacun l'énorme
différence avec les années 30 c'est
qu'il ya eu les années 30 et que donc
les erreurs qui ont été faits dans les
années 30 on les refait pas et c'est
pour ça c'est grâce à cette expérience
terrible des années 1930 et c'est pour
ça que la crise de 1929 est enseignée en
france que vous avez bruno le maire qui
même s'il comprend rien à l'économie
comprend suffisamment qu'il faut
effectivement sauver les entreprises
quoiqu'il en
c'est grâce à ça que la banque centrale
européenne même si christine lagarde le
comprends rien elle non plus à
l'économie prend les bonnes décisions
parce qu'ils ont autour d'eux des gens
qui ont les bons réflexes
parce que qu'est ce qui se passe dans
les années 30 c'est qu'encore une fois
on a un fonctionnement de la pure
économie de marché de la vraie économie
de marché que certains certains
souhaitent restaurer en france et qu'on
a quasiment jamais connues en france et
dont l'immense majorité des français ne
veulent pas
cette économie de marché livrée à
elle-même elle a détruit la démocratie
elle a conduit à la guerre caisse
c'était un économiste libéral il a écrit
un texte
il est en faveur du marché il est en
faveur de la liberté et il sait que la
première liberté si les libertés
politiques
c'est un homme qui est obsédé par la
question de la paix aussi de la paix
dans le monde et c'est pour ça qu'ils
participeront aux négociations de près
tout ce qu'ils auront lieu après la
seconde guerre mondiale qu'ils vont
mettre en place alors monétaire
international fabuleux qui va
s'effondrer au début des années 70 et
dont d'ailleurs l'effondrement conduira
directement à la crise pétrolière de
1973 15 s'il veut la liberté il veut la
paix et il sait que pour avoir la
liberté pour avoir la paix il faut qu'il
ya une stabilité dans la société et
c'est pour ça que la sécurité sociale
est créée en 1945
pourquoi est-ce que la sécurité sociale
écrit en 1945 dans tous les pays avancés
du monde sauf les adhésions c'est parce
que vous avez des gens qui ont connu la
crise des années 30
ce sont des gens qui sont favorables à
l'économie de marché qui sont favorables
à la propriété privée même si en france
encore une fois les communistes ont joué
un rôle essentiel dans la création de la
sécurité sociale et sécurité sociale et
a créé qu'en france le parti communiste
n'est pas aussi fort qu'en france dans
les autres pays vous avez des élites de
droite conservatrice dans les termes
actuels qu'on peut dire sans doute
sexistes sans doute tranquillement
raciste on a encore beaucoup de colonies
à l'époque loin on a encore dans cette
mythologie de la civilisation
occidentale et ces gens là ils ont vécu
l'effondrement du marché et donc de
façon strictement intéressés y savent
qu'il faut faire ce bon fabuleux dans
l'histoire de l'humanité et je pèse mes
mots
c'est que maintenant quand vous êtes
malade vous êtes payés que vous êtes au
chômage vous êtes payé quand vous êtes
vieux vous êtes payé quand vous avez des
enfants vous êtes payé pourquoi on le
fait on fait pas pour vous en faites
banon ont fait vous putsch et compte
continuer à consommer pardon et parce
que continuer à consommer vous allez
donner du boulot aux autres et donc
cette solidarité mécanique si on prenait
les termes du sociologue dürckheim ses
sonorités mécanique votre dépense votre
dépense de consommation ses deux revenus
de votre voisin c'est l'emploi de vos
doigts et donc la sécurité sociale cet
équilibre entre le marché l'intervention
publique
si les avants de trucs les plus géniaux
et je finirai là dessus et bien cette
histoire de la sécurité sociale les noms
des gens qui ont créé la sécurité
sociale elle n'est pas raconter cette
magnifique histoire elle n'est pas
enseigné au collège au lycée
[Musique]
pourquoi pourquoi est ce que cette
construction fabuleuse nous la
connaissons tous par coeur
pourquoi est-ce que nous passons notre
temps à râler contre le niveau des
impôts contre le niveau des cotisations
sociales
au lieu de nous réjouir chaque matin
d'avoir le sourire ou 9 ans 10 ans comme
dire pour paraphraser bruno le maire
[ __ ] je vis dans un pays où il ya la
sécurité sociale c'est la classe c'est
la classe
combien d'êtres que marsa et pourquoi
évidemment la droite mais quand même la
droite notions de droite comme la sécu
c'est bien mais content toucher les
allocs
quand même quand on est de droite donc
pourquoi est ce que les partis de gauche
les partis de droite écran journalistes
ne nous explique pas que nous avons
cette chance nous français la commune
s'est si bien bernard maris ce de
sourire parce qu'on a la sécu et qu'il
faut préserver ce trésor national qui
voit là au coeur du fonctionnement de
notre société de la solidarité entre
nous et de la paix et de la paix parce
que si vous continuez à tout détruire
eh ben on va revivre ce qui s'est passé
dans les années 30 au ralenti et c'est
ce que j'explique à mes étudiants depuis
des années il ya malheureusement des
paramètres très fort entre ans qu'on vit
aujourd'hui en europe
la montée de l'extrême droite en france
très très forte premier parti chez les
hommes jeunes aujourd'hui en france la
montée de l'extrême droite en europe qui
est la conséquence du délitement du
fonctionnement de l'économie de la
société
même si c'est reparti le mans pour des
raisons différentes donc la sécu c'est
ce qui fait qu'on vit pas la crise des
années 30 mais il ya un moment sur
l'arête et la destruction et donc comme
le dit bernard maris ce sourire souris
nous sommes français nous avons la sécu
devant des systèmes chez nous donc il
faut les préserver et des veaux et bien
merci beaucoup monsieur ravaux pour tous
ces mots à positif ces mots qui se
permettre de conclure avec le sourire et
des propos car les mouches de exactement
de notre système français dont on fait
pas assez dont on donne pas assez de
récompenser ont fait pas assez l'éloge
du système français on ne s'en rend pas
assez compte de la chance qu'on a de
vivre dans un système qui nous permet
d'être en bonne santé et de ne pas se
ruiner pour pour chaque problème qu'on
traverse dans notre quotidien
eh bien c'est la fin de cette entrevue
merci beaucoup monsieur ravaux pour
toutes ces réponses très claires on
ressent évidemment que vous êtes
enseignant vous êtes un très bon
enseignant tout est très pédagogue
on comprend bien où vous voulez en venir
vous répondez parfaite en question et
tout a été très clair nous avons pu
parler de croissance économique
d'héritage de fossé entre les classes
populaires et les classes très riche
nous avons pu parler également du
salaire minimum du capital de la classe
populaire dans la classe moyenne pardon
dans notre démocratie
on voit que ce sont vraiment des thèmes
qui sont abordés largement dans votre
ouvrage comme nous l'avons dit économie
on n'a pas tout essayé que nous
recommandons à tous nos auditeurs
évidemment et je vais laisser lucas pour
le mot de la fin encore une fois merci
beaucoup de sueur à vous et à très vite
merci merci lucas merci à vous monsieur
raoult encore une fois et merci à nos
chers auditeurs que j'invite à écouter
nos six premiers épisodes qui sont au
moins aussi formidable que celui-ci de
l'entrevue politique mais aussi à
consulter nos articles dossiers ou
tribune sur notre site web
copé au point org et à le suivre sur nos
réseaux sociaux instagram facebook
linkedin et twitter sous le nom de
scopeo l'observatoire pour être informé
sur les derniers contenus publiés sur
notre plateforme merci encore monsieur
amoureux et au revoir à tous merci à
vous les amis bonne journée tout le
monde lisez des vivants